Feels like now we're in this third stage where there's
a Chrome Firefox edge,
I guess it's called and brave.
And these are all seem like really exciting. I don't know,
innovative browsers. They're all kind of copying off of each other,
picking up the good stuff. Yeah.
There's evolution again, especially on tracking protection.
So privacy is this sort of global, um,
wave that's rising. I like to call it a wave because it's a large,
somewhat chaotic structure. It's not a unitary. Good.
You can't say I'm buying privacy for, you know, $3. I'm paying $3 for privacy.
Some people think of VPN does this and are disappointed when it fails them.
But often people use VPNs for region unlocking video or getting the best Netflix
capital. Exactly. Um, but privacy is, is not a unitary good it's complex.
And people are understanding it only over time. And if they get burned,
but there's a genie, that's not going back in the bottle. There,
people are fed up. Apple has responded to this. Apple was always making Safari.
I think more of a privacy branded browser from the very beginning.
I think it was probably Steve jobs. Safari had private windows,
private tabs before Firefox did. Um,
and these are only private in the sense that they don't leave local traces. Uh,
if you don't want them to turns out,
Safari does keep them around between shutdown,
but the canonical model is no local traces after you closed the private window.
No, no leftover traces that you went to, you know,
some site that you were embarrassed by or bought a gift for somebody you wanted
to keep secret. Um.
But there's still some level of tracking.
There's network tracking there's network.
Privacy is not guaranteed at all because you're using the same internet and ISP
as a public window, a non-private window. But sorry, had that early on,
they also have a cookie blocking policy that might take a little explaining
when you, if you know what a cookie is.
It's a little bit of storage in the browser indexed by the name of the site.
And it's really only the main name of the site, like be Aveda or, um,
you know, uh, something like, uh, npr.org. Um,
every site can store some information in a cookie.
Every time it's contacted by the browser.
The previous version is sent back and in the response from the server,
the cookies updated.
So it's this little bit of storage in the browser that the site can keep
updating and it can store an encrypted version of your login
credentials with timestamps.
So you can stay logged in without having to re type your password every time you
navigate, which is how it would be. If you didn't have cookies.
Those web protocols,
especially in the nineties are so-called stateless protocols.
So you go to your bank, you log in,
you go from your login confirmed page to your accounts view.
If you didn't have a cookie, you'd be logging in again,
every time you type in something. So that was the great thing about cookies,
lumens, really it in a hurry in 1994,
before I joined that scape and he did it for really holding that kind of
credential. Um,
but even then there was the image element embedded in the page and the image
gets fetched possibly from a different server.
And that request carries the last cookie, which could be empty at first.
And the response carries the updated cookie.
So just by having images and cookies,
you have tracking because that image server can be serving a little one by one
pixel and they still use the word pixel on ad tech.
And that pixel can be served from the same server embedded differently with
different URL spellings in the New York times. And ESPN,
as you go from one to the other, the image server can say,
I haven't got a cookie for you. It's empty. Initially,
I'm going to assign you user number one, two, three, four,
and then put a database entry in. And I see, by the way,
I was fetched the name of the path,
part of the URL that I was in the New York times.
So you're in New York times reader, and then you hit ESPN, same thing,
and the database gets updated. And the number user one, two, three,
four indexes in the database to a profile of you you've been trapped.
This was not intended. And it was too late to undo.
By the time I got the Netscape, um, I think Lou wanted to do Twinkies.
He called them and he was trying to solve several problems.
He wanted them to be bigger. Cause initially cookies had a short size limit.
I think he wanted to solve the third-party problem. But Tom Peck,
when the engineering manager that, Nope, no Twinkies, just cookies. We're done.
You're done son. And, um, that's how a lot of that stuff was.
That's how JavaScript, you know, um, got frozen,
like a fly in Amber in some ways with that sloppy equality operator that I made
because the early adopters and the cookie got stuck with this tracking hazard.
And then because Java scripts can be like images. They're embedded in the page.
By the time of Netscape three, I made that work. Uh,
you can get a request with the last cookie value and the response updates.
It that's a tracking mechanism and that's why you don't even need images to
track. Now you just use scripts. So this whole tracking, uh, economy evolved.
And it, it, it depended on these accidents of the nineties,
these unintended consequences.
Great. Some of the richest companies in the world, right? I mean,
it's the social media. All I got was t-shirts all I got is this crappy t-shirt.
Yeah. Uh, I mean, uh, so that's,
that's the fundamental problem the world is facing.
Now they're looking at what social media has created.
And they're looking at a world of looking at itself in the mirror
and seeing that privacy is actually something as opposed to like a nice
thing to have.
It's something that is actually should be fundamental to the way we interact
with the world as part of our tooling.
And that's where the brave browser comes in. And I suppose others as well,
applying with this idea, but brave is at the forefront of that.
So maybe can you describe what brave is and what are its key
principles and what's broken? What is it brave trying to fix?
I realized that these accidents like the third-party cookie,
the image or script that's tracking you or the, um,
the JavaScripts that can do an invisibly now that all stuff wasn't intended
and that Firefox had supported extensions,
that block some of these things I thought probably we should have browsers just
block some of these things by default, these were not intended.
And they're now unsafe. They're tracking you. There could be data breaches,
mal where distribution, um, you know, uh,
bullying and PSYOPs and other attacks on people. Um,
block that stuff, block that JavaScript. I'm Dr. Frankenstein monster here,
but obviously you go to Gmail.
There's so much a script there to make that amazing web client that's okay.
That's first party JavaScript.
So how do you tell the first from the third party? And it's not easy,
it's not a matter of just what's embedded from a different server because a lot
of publishers use benign scripts from unrelated domains or apparently
unrelated domains.
So you ended up having to develop sort of human and machine learning,
practice around blocking. And at brave,
we did that from the start and built a research team to help drive it and
automate it. We realized that protecting people needed machine-learning.
And around 2017 spring, I talked to my friends at Apple about this too.
And they were also doing what they call intelligent tracking prevention,
which uses local machine learning in the browser. And the funny thing is we,
you know, great, great minds think alike. We were,
they were taking their third-party cookie blocker.
That was insofar from the old days and making it not have a big loophole,
because what they did was in 2003, when Sarah came out, they said,
we're going to block cookies that are from those third party embedded
elements where you've never visited that site before.
So I'm going to pick it up and add company that got sold to at and T.
So I'm not picking on anybody unfairly app, nexus.com.
If you've ever been to app nexus.com. Nope. I had never been there,
but I guarantee you 10 years ago, you probably had, if you're using Firefox,
you had a cookie third party cookie, cause you were being tracked by them.
And they were using that cookie to fill up a profile of you in Safari.
As long as the user never went to app nexus, that cookie will not be set.
And that was a real move for privacy early on, uh,
when Joseph was still around in Safari,
but it had this loophole that if you do go to app nexus,
then why it's okay to be a third-party cookie.
And so at nexus did something very naughty. They took their ad partners,
put the actual ad, you click on. And they said, Hey,
add a little script so that when somebody clicks on the ad,
before it goes to your landing page,
redirect to AppNexus and we'll redirect to the landing page. And by doing that,
they set a first party cookie and they got waitlisted. So it was a loophole.
They exploited intelligent tracking prevention and Safari was sophisticated
enough to counteract this and it did other things and it's evolved since they
did it. And we've evolved brave too.
And so when I say machine and human learning, there's a real, um,
set of techniques here.
They have to fight the same fascinating problem for printing, right?
Anytime you have a little bit of storage in the browser associated with a
website. If the bag I can get 32 websites, each one has a bit of storage.
That's 32 bits. You can turn the bit on or off. You can make 4 billion numbers.
You can make an identifier. It's called a super cookie. Sometimes it's a
weaker ways that are statistical. They're called fingerprinting.
You have to block all of them and you have to not only automate,
you want to work in the web standards body to put privacy in by default,
by design, from the get go, not added as an afterthought or, you know,
go hog-wild with new web APIs,
add a bunch more local storage or fingerprint surface area.
And that's been a struggle too,
because guess who's the new Microsoft in the standards body it's Google,
and they're not in favor of privacy first. They,
they want to do privacy their way only under, I would say market pressure,
but with Apple and with brave leading the way we,
we block third party cookies almost without exception. So we just blocked them.
And that gives us a very strong privacy, uh, benefit.
But it also means some sites just don't work right.
Embedded YouTube videos find that work, right?
So we're adapting in similar way to, Apple's done with ITP to make,
um, third party cookies blocked,
but to sort of simulate what looks like a working third party
cookie for the site,
it essentially tries to partition each site and its third parties into its own
sort of thing.
Got it. And so, and like, like you said, is this both like a human,
uh, fine tuning issue and a machine learning problem.
So humans learn, then they train the machine learning.
But you know, uh,
maybe Google side or including Google there's millions of dollars,
if not be billions of dollars to be made from fighting the ways
of brains.
That's right. And it's been a interesting change from when we started in 2015,
when we started, you know,
ad blocking extensions ad block plus was one of the big ones it's sort of in
Firefox in 2006,
I believe had gotten to a certain level of use around the world and browsers
like see web,
you see browser in Asia had some amount of ad blocking built in and on by
default. So a page fare was a startup, uh,
and they measured ad blocking adoption. And they tried to say, Hey publishers,
you're, you know,
30% of the visitors to a Pitchfork are wired to kind of Nass properties or
using ad blockers.
If we can somehow convince them to lower their ad blocking for your site,
that could be like a 43% lift. Right. Um, and the three sevens,
well that's easier said than done and paid is.
And others source point that many others tried to either smuggle ads through or
cajole the user into letting ads appear. And it didn't really work.
And meanwhile,
the ad blocking adoptions just continued intelligent tracking prevention Safari
in 2017,
brave from 2016 on with very strong cookie blocking and other protections.
And this, this is not going away. The publishers used to rage against it.
Like we would try to say, we can help you.
You're dealing with users who are already blocking all your ads.
We can try to put back, uh, some economics that help the user and you,
that led to the basic attention token that we started with Bitcoin.
We can be your friend.
Don't just fingerprint us as an ad-blocker and treat us as an enemy.
But in 2015 or 16, it was like, nah, you're an ad-blocker get out of here.
I hate you. And by 2017 or 18, it's like,
something's happening the app walking's not stopping.
And we're all getting sort of pulled on the Google's plantation through
amp amp or, you know, we're,
we're getting killed by the Google ads system we use because it's taken all the
revenue or, you know,
it's permitting or some other vendors we use are permitting ad fraud.
And so a fake New York times is getting paid by the market or running an ad that
a bot clicks on and the real New York times it's supposed to get that it doesn't
get it. Um, and there's something really broken about that kind of system.
And that, that fraud is mediated through Google's ad exchange,
which is the biggest of them all. And Google takes a fee.
There's a flip side of that, which is malware distribution.
Malvertising where fake advertisers put malware payloads in
or low explicate loaders in JavaScript.
And they smuggled them in ads onto real publisher pages.
The ad exchange takes the fee. Now I'm not a lawyer.
I'm not going to say this is a Rico predicate,
but why is the ad exchange facilitating fraud and malware distribution and
taking a feed? It's not right.